straight ahead
online crime daily shocking new
allegations in the deaths of actress
brittany murphy and her husband
simon jack a mother's battle to reopen
the 11 year old cases
she was a fantastic person she had full
of energy and fun but she was terrified
of dying
rapper tory lanez pleads not guilty to
shooting fellow rapper megan the
stallion in the foot
but could more charges be coming a
former pro baseball player convicted of
triple murder
should brandon willie martin face the
death penalty his mother's emotional
plea to spare his life
he would be a dagger in my heart
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
nearly 11 years after actress brittany
murphy died unexpectedly
her mother-in-law is speaking out on the
questions she has
about her death and the death of her son
screenwriter simon manjack
it was the one thing that she was always
said
i'm going to die young and it was
something that she
almost knew i can't say that there was
any conspiracy
i can't say that things were wrong all i
can say
for me personally things not add up
linda monjack is raising these questions
in a new podcast
red carpet rendezvous law and crime
dailies anjanet levy spoke with the host
who looks into the untimely deaths of a
celebrity couple
brittany murphy was only 32 years old
when she died suddenly in late 2009
and the death of her husband just five
months later has prompted a lot of
questions over the years
the coroner in los angeles determined
that both murphy and simon manjack
died of pneumonia and anemia the drug
hydrocodone was found in murphy's system
along with some medications used to
treat cold symptoms
monjack also had heart problems rumors
have swirled for years about the
possibility murphy used drugs or had an
eating disorder
things she vehemently denied before she
died some have even suggested she could
have been murdered
a claim her mother sharon murphy has
denied in the past
lauren conlon interviewed simon jack's
mother for her podcast
you know i got to thinking that this
still just doesn't make sense to me her
death was so
strange and so bizarre that i just
wanted to do a little bit of digging
both of these people claim to be
holistic
in one documentary but then they've got
all this prescription medication
and brittany doesn't do drugs yet
over-the-counter pills were found in her
system
it's all very strange and and again just
not to beat a dead horse but it doesn't
add up
forensic pathologist dr cyril wecht has
called for the investigation to be
reopened in the past
he has a lot of questions including why
more testing wasn't done on tissue and
hair samples
to determine why brittany murphy had so
many heavy metals in her system
the 11th anniversary of murphy's death
is next month
for law and crime daily i'm anginette
levy
thanks angenet and some more news out of
hollywood former movie producer and
convicted sex offender harvey weinstein
is sick again in prison his publicist
tells me weinstein has a fever
and is being monitored by his staff at a
new york penitentiary
weinstein was sentenced to 23 years in
prison for charges of rape and criminal
sexual acts
he reportedly contracted coven 19 in
march while in jail
but was never officially diagnosed he is
awaiting extradition to los
angeles where he'll face additional sex
assault allegations
a tennessee family can sleep easy
tonight after some much-needed good news
law on crime's terry austin has more
brian nine-year-old jordan gorman went
missing from his home on
sunday but thanks to quick thinking by
rescuers he's safely
back with his family a statement amber
alert was
issued in tennessee when jordan
disappeared
five search teams scoured the heavily
wooded area behind his home
after two days he was found under the
blue tarp he said he used to build
himself a shelter
the tennessee bureau of investigation
says jordan was
cold and hungry but is otherwise in
pretty good spirits
a great story an attorney for rapper
tory lanez appeared in a los angeles
court
as new allegations emerge in his
shooting case against fellow rapper
megan the stallion lanes is accused of
shooting megan the stallion in the
foot when the two got into an argument
on their way home from a pool party
in the hollywood hills in an interview
with gq magazine megan vistallion said
elaine's attempted to offer her hush
money to stay quiet
lanes denied this happened lanes is
charged with assault and carrying an
unregistered firearm he pled not guilty
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney eklund mercy along with terry
austin
terry the whole hush money allegations
is just like he said she said but when
you're accused of shooting a woman in
the foot
does tory lanez have a foot to stand on
here
no i don't think tory lanez has a foot
to stand on but i do
think megan the rapper does or the
stallion does i think
she absolutely has you know
evidence based on the fact that she
showed pictures
of her foot that was shot up and there
were also
individuals who were in the you know suv
when it occurred so
she could absolutely get them to
cooperate the information that she gave
that he shot her in the foot
and so yeah i think megan the stallion
really has a good case here and the only
reason she didn't talk about it before
is because she said she was trying to
protect him
now eckland you've represented rappers
and artists uh
tory lanez is basically going out not
just in his music but publicly saying
he's innocent
after you saw megan the stallion's foot
injury what conversation would you be
having with lanes
if he was your client right now well
first you could talk about um
any offer of money can be excluded as
you know
settlement negotiations but then i would
talk to tori and tell him to
look around and just just have a seat
have a collective seat have a reflective
and collective sleep
and shut up like silence is golden just
be quiet just hold your mouth and just
shut up like this is what like the bane
of every criminal defense term
like just stop talking just silence
silence is is gold in here shut up
that's that's what i that's what i tell
him shut up
you heard it i could tell him quiet
there because of course those lyrics can
be used against him
still ahead on the lawn crime daily
police in wisconsin discovered a couple
dead in their home
but quickly realized their teenage
daughter was missing how jamie kloss
escaped her kidnapping
and later who placed the pizza order
that ended in ashley biggs murdered by
her ex
we break down the ohio trial of erica
stefanco
the case against an ohio woman accused
of helping murder her husband's ex-wife
over a custody dispute is growing
prosecutors say erika stefanko placed a
fake pizza order at domino's
to lure ashley biggs to her death biggs
worked as a delivery driver
and was later found dead in her car in a
cornfield
chad cobb plead guilty to murdering
biggs and helped to implicate stefanco
at trial prosecutors played a recording
his mother made of the defendant
allegedly confessing to her involvement
but on cross
the defense questioned her motives you
want to hear
more and more about
about what erica has to say a person who
is known to drink heavily and
it's had at least one drink in her we
had a meeting and i left it on
we did not leave the building until the
end of
week discussion the avowed purpose
was to hope that erica
will say something damning
no it was more because of the kids
and always whenever she was upset about
something
calling you know withholding the kids
until everybody was in her words on the
same page
we would not get visitation
cop isn't getting a plea deal to testify
but the defense asked his mother if he
still has something to gain
with stefanko behind bars
no like i stated we'd seen him a few
days prior
and they were getting ready to go on
vacation
was he acting erratically though no
did he take the attitude of women should
be
kept barefoot and pregnant down on the
farm
no the victim's manager says he
remembers a woman
placing a pizza order shortly before
closing
it popped up as a new customer in our
database they also asked for the
delivery to go to the back door
actually especially when they're going
right down the road ashley would have
been back here
real quick and i would say about 20
minutes had went by
and i you know i stopped cleaning and i
was
like well what's going on i started
making phone calls
i started calling her first i actually
started blowing her up calling her
one after another after another did you
ever try attempting calling the number
back
that placed the order um i do believe so
yes were you able to get an answer on
that phone
no terry a big part of this case is
going to be the credibility the
credibility sorry of the witnesses
which ones are you believing so far well
you know brian i've listened to many of
the witnesses and i think there's
several
chad was really from prison quite
credible he basically
put erica at the scene and he said she
made that call
to have the pizza delivered so that was
critical and i also think
the general manager of the dominoes
matthew travis i thought he was
excellent he
actually put the timeline together so we
know what happened when ashley
went to that you know lot where they
ultimately killed her
and then you know finally i'll say i
think cynthia cobb did a great job too
the mother i think
she definitely defended her son in the
case so
i think there were a number of credible
witnesses all right it seems pretty
positive for the prosecution
eclin the prosecution as we know doesn't
have to prove motive but
it can help does the motive here make
sense to you or do you think the defense
can really pull it apart
uh the motive here makes no sense i
actually don't find any of the witnesses
credible and i'm just waiting on the
defense to actually
find that line find that string so they
can just
pull it and pull the case you know apart
it's already flimsy at best i feel like
all the testimony
is biased there is some type of um
allegiance to
chad in this case so i feel that um
they have to find it in and i think that
they'll be able to really destroy the
prosecution's case
i mean peop there are interested parties
here the man
pled guilty i don't know what else
i think that the the defense has a
chance here to really to really make it
happen
and of course at the end of the trial we
all know there's often that charge we
could tell the jury this is an
interested party
and you could take their testimony in a
certain way
still ahead of jury is deliberating life
or death for a former pro baseball
player convicted of a triple homicide
and we'll take you inside the courtroom
as a courageous young girl
stands up to her kidnapper
when 13 year old jamie closs went
missing from her wisconsin home
a nationwide effort was launched to find
her lawn crime founder dan
abrams takes us inside the courtroom
where her kidnapper and the killer of
her parents
admits to what he's done on the a e
network production court cam
we're inside the barren county justice
center in barron wisconsin
this is defendant jake patterson
convicted of killing james and denise
claus
parents of 13 year old jamie closs
patterson had no connection to the
family
but when he first saw jaime walking off
a school bus
he began hatching his plan
on the night of october 15 2018
patterson arrived at the kloss home
armed with a shotgun he shot jamie's
father at the front door
then trapped jamie and her mother in the
bathroom as they called 911
once inside the bathroom patterson shot
and killed jamie's mother
and took the 13 year old prisoner
88 days after she witnessed her parents
murder
jaime escaped patterson's home and made
it to safety
patterson was immediately arrested
he confessed to the crimes and pled
guilty to all charges
jamie was too traumatized to attend the
trial but wrote a powerful statement
that was read by her attorney prior to
sentencing
patterson listened just a few feet away
last october jake patterson took a lot
of things that i love away from me
it makes me the most sad that he took
away my mom and my dad
he thought that he could own me but he
was wrong
i will always have my freedom and he
will not
then it was patterson's chance to speak
i'll just say that
i would do like absolutely anything
to take back what i did you know
i would die i would
do absolutely anything to
to bring them back nope
i don't care about me i just
i'm just so sorry that's
despite patterson's newfound remorse
judge james barber
is unmoved there is no doubt
in my mind that you are one of the most
dangerous men to ever walk
on this planet you are the embodiment of
evil
and the public can only be safe if you
are incarcerated until you die
the judge gave patterson the maximum
sentence for the state of wisconsin
life without parole
when we come back a former pro baseball
player convicted of triple homicide is
about to learn his fate
stay with us
a california jury is in deliberations
deciding if a former pro baseball player
will spend the rest of his life in
prison
or be sentenced to death for a triple
homicide brandon willie martin was
convicted of slugging to death
with a baseball bat his father his uncle
and a security system installer
prosecutors say he killed them in a rage
after losing an
800 thousand dollar contract but his
defense says he has schizophrenia and
had a long history
of mental illness the defendant's mother
made an emotional plea to the jury
to spare his life you lost your brother
right
he did it you lost your husband right
and now this jury's inside whether you
lose your stuff is that right
yes chris first i want you to know
how sorry i am that brandon has this
mental
brain disorder we wouldn't wish that
about anybody
if brandon was executed how would that
affect
you i've had so much loss so much debt
it's so profound i do not want to lose
another member of my family it would be
a dagger in my heart
on cross the prosecution asked the
defendant's mother about
his violent nature and what evidence she
has of his mental illness
are you talking about an exam a medical
x-ray or mri correct no he was too
paranoid to take one
back in 2015 there was an incident
where he choked you right he had both
his hands on my neck yes
okay did he or did he not choke you he
had two hands on my neck sir
brandon talking to himself wasn't the
normal you talking to yourself
playing baseball or shooting a shot that
you missed it's very different
it's a conversation that goes on and on
and on it doesn't stop
right but this is an interview that took
place the day
after the killings correct
yes when i was in total shock yes you're
right right but you're still telling the
truth correct
yes to the best of my ability okay and
you were asked
if brandon ever talked to himself
in your responses um i think we all talk
to ourselves
yes probably if that's what the record
says
terry that cross of the defendant's
mother didn't sit well with me i mean at
the end of the day
she's a victim in this what do you think
of the prosecution's tactic as to how
they went after her
well you know i think you have to be
very careful
when you are attacking someone who could
be considered a victim as in this case
the mother
so i don't know if that's going to go
over well as far as you know the final
outcome is concerned
but i agree with you i think that you
have to be very careful as a defense
attorney
not to or rather as a prosecutor not to
attack when you're doing your
cross-examination
thank you eckland the jury is still in
deliberations for the penalty phase
why do you think it's taking so long oh
because you had
the mom did an excellent job she was man
she was trained
um she was very prepped you can tell
that she was prepped
you can tell that um she understood the
questions and she answered them
um the choking question i was like how
she answered that was amazing
but i think the jury is thinking oh we
have this gifted kid
we have this athlete who had the
pressure of being an
athlete and being a gifted kid who who
lost it
um because the one thing that he was
told by his father his
uncle his mom you're gonna make it
you're gonna make it
out of this you're gonna be a superstar
was taken away from him
and the world stopped and he stopped it
as well
so um i think that the jury is kind of
really
humanizing him and trying to put
themselves in that position
to see that i don't believe that he
requires the death penalty i think he
just needs help
so i think that that's what the jury is
really debating with right now
i like it you picked up on the word help
because we also learned the defendant
refused to be evaluated
for mental competency in the jail cells
and so how do you help a client who
can't really help themselves because of
their mental illness
oh i just i file i follow emotions i
file the motion
and i will do it i will do it ex parte
and i will file the motion
um because i cannot represent him if i
don't know if
anything is knowing will will willfully
involuntarily
so for the purposes of my bar card and
how it fits in my pocket
i will make a motion for a psychological
evaluation
and so it seems that like there was a
major point here
that they couldn't get that evaluation
and to help out here
terry um just quickly do you think it's
going to be a big issue
not having a mental evaluation well i
think the jury's going to decide
that he has mental issues for sure
thanks terry and thank you for joining
us here at long crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss
justice in america
you